let's talk about the three common
nutritional deficiencies
in sciatica as well as carpal tunnel
syndrome now satica can really be a pain
in the butt literally you have this pain
that goes right on the back of the leg
and it can really affect someone if
they're sitting or driving and carpal
tunnel syndrome can be a big issue and
sometimes people go for surgery when in
fact they probably didn't need to do
that so today I'm going to discuss three
common nutritional deficiencies okay and
they involve the B vitamins B1 b6 and
b12 so we're going to discuss
um a little bit on how to differentiate
if your problem is more of a B6
deficiency or a B12 deficiency or a B1
but these three vitamins are intimately
involved in the nervous system and
especially sciatic nerve and carpal
tunnel syndrome which is pain or
numbness in your wrist so I want to just
Dive Right In let's first start with
vitamin B6 it's called pyridoxine now
there's different forms of B6 pyridoxine
is the inactive form it has to convert
to another form to be active the active
form is called paradoxyl 5 phosphate or
p5p this happens in the liver but you
have to realize how important B6 is in a
lot of problems including the nervous
system because it is involved in over a
160 different enzymes okay that's our
enzyme Pathways so you can have all
sorts of problems but today we're going
to focus more on the nerve problems that
can occur now B6 helps to make myelin
sheath okay that's one thing it does
myelin sheath is the coating around the
nerve and when you lose that coding the
nerve stops working you start having
symptoms like burning numbness tingling
pain because that nerve keeps everything
going keeps the nerves flowing and so
the protein that builds myelin which is
a type of fat insulation is dependent on
B6 as well as B6 helps produce
neurotransmitters
those nerve Communications that travel
through the nervous system which is a
little different than hormones hormones
travel through the blood as far as B6 is
concerned the two big ones are serotonin
and dopamine B6 is especially important
in protecting the nerve Integrity
specifically the sensory nerves okay
more than the motor nerves so there's
two types of nerves one that controls
the muscle movement and there's also the
sensory nerve that has everything to do
with pain and different Sensations like
it can produce burning pain or numbness
or which is a lack of pain anything that
you can feel is more of a sensory nerve
and one big one is sciatica and another
one is carpal tunnel syndrome so I
remember in practice I had a machine
that measured how fast the sensory
nerves traveled through your arms it's
called conduction nerve velocity testing
and we would check these sensory nerves
and unfortunately back then I had no
clue about B6 and other vitamin and how
they can greatly affect the nerves so B6
helps increase the conduction of the
nerves the velocity of nerves how fast
the nerves transmit nerve signals B6 is
also involved in the metabolism of the
nervous system as well and B6 can also
affect the nerves of the eyes and if
you're deficient you can get myopathy
which is nearsightedness which is
difficulty in seeing far away B6
deficiencies are also involved in
seizures okay so if you know anyone who
has seizures you should definitely
recommend B6 and or have them watch this
video now there's a paradox with B6 okay
that I'm going to talk about it's a
mystery because in some cases when
people start taking large quantities of
vitamin B6 they end up expressing
symptoms of ab6 deficiency
so that's a little bit of an odd thing
but I'm going to explain exactly why
that occurs apparently these two forms
of the vitamin the inactive and the
active can compete with each other
so let's say for example you start
taking a lot of of the precursor to B6
which is the paradoxine you could end up
blocking the active form okay creating a
deficiency of B6 creating sensory nerve
problems now just think about this the
rdas the requirements
for B6
are very small it's like 1.4 to 2.1
milligrams okay well if you ever buy
vitamin B6 in a tablet form
it comes in like 50 milligrams or 100
milligrams or sometimes 250 milligrams
and this could be like 2 000 times more
than the rdas and most the time people
don't know the difference between these
two types of B6 and they end up taking a
lot of the inactive form and then they
end up with the B6 toxicity they
actually start experiencing neurological
problems and they did not connect the
dots so straight off the bat if you have
a B6 deficiency I'm going to recommend
taking the active form not the inactive
form of B6 now the other thing you
should know is that in about 36 percent
of all supplements sold you'll see B6 as
the inactive version so you could be
unknowingly getting a lot of this B6 and
actually creating B6 deficiencies
without your knowledge so how does one
become deficient in B6 well
by taking the wrong form of B6 in large
amounts lets you have some inflammation
in your gut or some type of problem with
Celiac or Crohn's that could be a
problem or maybe you had your
gallbladder up as we age it becomes more
difficult to absorb B6 certain
medications uh block vitamin B6 alcohol
will do it birth control pills will
cause a deficiency even your genetics
there are genetic variations that can be
picked up on a gene test that can cause
a weakness within your system in
converting the inactive to the active as
well as just the absorption of B6 so in
that case you would want to take larger
amounts of the active form of B6 to
correct this problem so you may not be
able to get B6 from just your diet in
general depending on what you eat
because foods that are very high in B6
are usually animal protein foods fish
Meats things like that and of course if
you were a vegan or vegetarian you're
more susceptible to becoming B6
deficient also the form of B6 in plants
is not as bioavailable now if you're a
smoker if you're a diabetic you could be
deficient in B6 if you drink a lot of
coffee let's say you drink over four
cups of coffee a day you can be
deficient in B6 the next most important
vitamin involved with nerve problems is
B12 I've done lots of videos on this
topic it's very very Insidious because
it can sneak up on you and by the time
you know you have a B12 deficiency
potentially it could be too late because
it can create some serious damage but
when you think about B12 you want to
think about myelin okay myelin sheath
that's that coding I just mentioned that
surrounds the nerve and allows the nerve
impulses to travel without B12 you can't
make myelin so B12 has everything to do
with nerve regeneration with myelin
production and with nerve growth factors
okay so B12 is very very important and I
would not recommend taking the synthetic
version called
cyanocobolamine I would recommend taking
the
methylcobolamine which is the natural
form
now virtually the same reasons why you
are deficient in B6 could be the same
reasons why you're deficient in B12 like
drinking too much alcohol being a
diabetic having malabsorption birth
control pills definitely genetics which
is very very common but there's some
other things as well like for example
not having enough stomach acid how would
you know if you don't have enough
stomach acid well you get acid reflux
you'd get GERD you may have gastritis
but I think the two main reasons why
people are deficient in B12 is either
they don't eat animal products they
don't eat red meat they don't have liver
they mainly do plant based foods or
grains
and the other reason is genetics I've
been diving into DNA recently and and
boy B12 deficiency is a common problem
with so many people and it's such a
simple problem to solve if you
understand that methylcobalamine is the
form that you want to take but another
B12 deficiency is when someone takes a
lot of folic acid that can create a
hidden B12 deficiency I did a whole
video on that and then we have B1
I've done videos on this too a B1
deficiency usually shows up as
peripheral neuropathy and it's usually
involved with diabetes or pre-diabetes
or someone who has really bad insulin
resistance problems because
B1 is all about helping you metabolize
carbohydrates and sugar so the more
carbs or more sugar you eat
the more B1 you're going to need to
metabolize that and so that person
usually ends up with a B1 deficiency and
they start having neurological problems
in the bottom of the feet but they also
can have them in the hands they can also
have these problems in other syndromes
like sciatica so that would be a little
bit of a differentiating factor do you
have a history of eating a lot of carbs
do you have pre-diabetes then definitely
include B1 but other things can create a
B1 deficiency too like too much coffee
too much tea but B1 is involved with
supplying blood flow to the nervous
system and without that B1 you basically
starve off the nervous system the blood
supply and oxygen that it needs and you
can have all sorts of issues the type of
B1 that I would recommend would be
benfotamine which is a fat soluble
version of B1 and that will penetrate
the nerves about 25 percent stronger and
it's great for helping with the myelin
sheath B1 also is a powerful antioxidant
and it can counter the complications
from diabetes not just in the nerves
that go to your muscles but the nerves
that go to your eyes and also other
tissues in the heart in the kidney so
anyway I wanted to bring up your
awareness on three really important
vitamins involved in sciatica pain that
can greatly help you if you start taking
them you can take all three or just
narrow down the one that indicates more
to you but this information is something
that I don't have in some other videos
so I wanted to include it but there are
other causes of sciatic pain as well and
one is that you lost the normal curve of
the lower back and if you have not seen
that video okay with a simple solution I
put it up right here check it out